it's
i think more and more women have been
told that
in order for them to get credit they
have to be super career driven they have
to make loads of money they have to
focus on achievement and so when women
pursue that they tend to be in their
masculine energy a lot
and being a stay-at-home wife or raising
a family it doesn't it's not seen as as
valuable
but
i would argue insane
to some point i agree with you but argue
and say like if women are
single parents
um and had to raise their children by
themselves they're looked upon as
masculine as well but they're being at
home raising the family and
to some for often of their own or not on
their own like the the father of their
children is not there but they still
have to raise the children but they are
willing to be that housewife etc um but
they looked upon us being masculine
because they're saying well you're a
single parent and you're a single parent
for a reason so i feel sometimes as a
female regardless what role we play is
sometimes hard to kind of say all right
which way do we go do we go down the
feminine route or do we have to go down
sometimes the message i think you can be
both though
like femininity and masculinity it's all
contextual and it's not black and white
so for me personally in business i show
up as pretty masculine like you know the
very typical boss business babe whatever
and then in my relationship i'm the
opposite and that's because i had to
unlearn a lot of the social programming
that told me that my worth came from
career success and i had to relearn like
what men really want in a relationship
which is they want a woman to make them
feel appreciated supported they want a
woman to like bring out his masculine
even more and play the feminine role
they really look down
on being the mother now if you just
wanted to go home and you work maybe
part-time if you can't afford to do it
and then
everyone just looks down on you on that
that's a bad thing to do you've done
that for a man i find
that's yeah my friend ali i was telling
you guys before the show she went viral
for just saying yeah my um my husband's
my boss i work for him yeah he makes the
decision
yeah yeah
i was the one behind the camera yeah
yeah that was like that was my account
yeah that's crazy and like all the all
the comments were basically saying how
could you trust him like he could just
leave you high and drive but it's like
everything you do has risk
like there's risk in being a single
parent there's after like you can get
married you could get divorced like
life is risk i think what we're talking
about here with what you said lavina
what you said hannah is about emotional
intelligence so it's being able to
switch on and switch off and apply
yourself effectively in different
situations and scenarios whether it's
masculine energy or feminine yeah yeah
and just understanding the two and then
when to play which role accordingly
yeah
sometimes i feel
men struggle with that as well
like you're absolutely right men do want
to feel like they are the man and they
want to feel wanted and they want to
feel like their purpose in the
relationship but sometimes there are
some men
if they've never been shown that as
a young person or a child
they won't know how to do that as an
adult and sometimes as a woman we can be
patients about i can show you that but
if they're not willing to receive
that love from it's very hard
relationships are just the thing that
not a lot of people taught and because
people don't do the self-development
work on themselves they expect something
else somebody else outside of them to
validate who they are and what they do
whereas they don't have that internal
self-belief that internal validation
which is which is important yeah in
saying that as well i feel like based on
the solely of personal experience right
um as a young man i used to wear glasses
isn't it so
throughout my whole secondary school
year i had glasses on so i didn't really
have the confidence to be like to
approach women in that sort of way and
format
because
and then the moment i turned 19 got
laser eye surgery
lost my glasses
hit the gym i mean did all these things
i never used to do
and then and realized i was like yo i'm
kind of i'm kind of a spice right now
i'm kind of good
do i say and i never went to uni and
then i lost my virginity when i was at
uni
and then that just opened up a whole new
doors of experience that i didn't
experience before so
um when it comes to the younger men
coming up nowadays i feel like yeah they
have no
because they have no guidance do you
know what i mean they have no one to say
well how how are they supposed to be
taught about women if like i i want to
say aren't half of people raised by
single mothers or like
that i was going to get to that point
i am raised by a single mother
when it came to asking my dad about for
stuff like hey dad
you know what i mean how does it do to
you know do certain sexual activities
with a woman
do you know he wasn't around
straight up
no problem i said it on my channel i'm
saying on post yeah yeah yeah i was
thinking um sorry uh no go on
women have been been encouraged to go
off and be independent on their own
and if their meaning was to you know
find a husband have children look after
children and their men were to
get a job find a wife and then provide
for him and the women have gone off the
men have nothing now to look what
doesn't there's no wives around
so they're just completely
what percent of women would you say
want to be wives and what percent of
women would you say our wives i want to
hear from the men
and your experience with dating
i bet a lot
lie to themselves
so i bet it's higher than they think
so i'm going to say about 80 percent
want to be wives yeah
only furry
are wives yeah okay yeah i think i would
i would agree a lot with that i think a
lot of women want to be wives but they
don't have the substance or the skills
to actually support the lifestyle
of the person that they would ideally
like to be with so then they end up with
somebody that is not fully compatible
with and they go oh my relationship's
all right it will it will last and you
know we have our ups and downs and they
have those sorts of tumultuous
relationships that don't really work out
long term
but most women don't have the the skill
sets to be
wives to the men that they aspire to be
with and what skills would you say those
are
patience communication i think
communication is one of the most the
most powerful ones because a lot of
women have
in my experience at least have a lot of
self doubt and they don't
they don't know how to be supportive to
somebody else they don't know how to
communicate powerfully with somebody
else in a way that
helps their relationship to grow helps
their relationship to flourish and helps
their relationship to be really
effective mm-hmm
do you think women have self-doubt
because i find them to be more
narcissistic than ever
yeah is it is it a fake narcissistic
though because it's like an external
narcissism but an internal i don't feel
good about this i don't feel i'm worth
it
i feel like
i'll just like even at carnival i was
asking like rate yourself one to ten and
they would say ten i'm like oh god again
okay and then i'd ask i'd say well
aren't you perfect doesn't mean you're
perfect she's like well i'm not perfect
but i am and then they'd say special but
isn't it kind of narcissistic to think
you're special yeah like
everyone thinks they're special like
it's been proven in psychology that
everyone as many of you know i was just
banned on tick tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible